almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it so we've
been covering the Sham treatments and
cures for the virus from all sorts of
different grifters we've looked at some
well-known Christian televangelist
grifters like Jim Baker he's been
selling a so-called silver solution
we've looked at propagandist and
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones he's
selling a coronavirus toothpaste that he
claims kills coronavirus we've also seen
people like Kenneth Copeland who are
making money by receiving donations for
praying away coronavirus through the
television today I have something very
very different today I have video of
Okeechobee Commissioner Bryant Culpepper
this is Okeechobee County in Florida
this guy says the virus can't survive
high temperatures so what you can do is
you take a hair dryer and you blow hot
air down your throat aspirate the hot
air coming out of the blow dryer to kill
the virus now this is real this guy says
he says I was a paramedic and this makes
sense to him take a look this might
sound kind of silly but being in the
medical field that I was as a paramedic
it started to make a lot of sense one of
the things that was pointed out in this
interview with one of the doctors for
most doctors that has studied the corona
virus says that the nasal passages
passages and the nasal membranes or the
coolest part of the body that's why the
virus tends to go there until it then
becomes healthy enough to go into the
lungs
this is sounds really goofy and it did
to me too but it works once the
temperature reaches 136 degrees
Fahrenheit the virus falls apart and
just disintegrates okay and I said well
how would you get the temperature up to
132 degrees the answer was you use a
blow dryer because it's capable of doing
that so you hold a blow dryer in front
of your face and you
Hale with your nose and it kills all the
viruses in your nose okay there's an
idea right now another person in the
room immediately warned people about
disinformation that is spreading quickly
this is not just dumb it's incredibly
dangerous and irresponsible to say and
here's the key part okay so he talks
about this so-called cure or treatment
someone else in the room says you've got
to be really careful about nonsense you
hear on social media and he says no no
no I didn't get it from social media I
got it from Oh a n1 American news that's
that insane right-wing propaganda
channel which Donald Trump increasingly
has been promoting take a look at this
social media I would not even have
brought that up this was on a way and
one American news network which is the
fastest-growing national network on
cable and it's the new Fox News if you
want to know the truth and it was a
doctor and it what did have his
credentials that he has been one of the
foremost doctors and studying you know
how this is transmitted and that's where
that came from and I agree with you
there's a lot of baloney out there on
social media you gotta be very careful
proudly saying I got this from Oh a n
Culpepper was ultimately shamed into
apologizing for this he posted to his
personal Facebook page I am sorry for
comments I made I was only trying to
give comfort to those in Okeechobee who
have no insurance to treat their
families th e re I should have ignored
the comments that I perceived as hateful
and the embarrassment I caused to my
fellow commissioners in our
administration administrator and her
staff I will not offer any more
suggestions unless they are tried are
proven I ask all of you for forgiveness
for anything offensive I've uh turd
during these exchanges now I looked at
this guy's Facebook page it may not
shock you that this guy's Facebook page
is riddled with insane approach from
propaganda for example a few days before
his apology he posted absolutely when he
tried to stop Chinese from coming into
America the left called him racist
capital L on left when he tried to build
a wall to protect Americans the left
called him racist capital
are on racist his post looked just like
Trump's tweets racist is the left's
favorite word to destroy a Republican
when they in fact are the true racist
they didn't call Obama a racist when he
locked up little kids in cages and
separated them from their parents and he
deported more Mexicans the Trump and
then once more I mean it's just like the
capitalization the grammar the spelling
it's all like Trump's tweets just to
give you a little more context about the
guy tweeting suggesting rather that you
inhale hot air from a blow dryer to
treat coronavirus he posted about an
MSNBC dolt as he called them saying does
this talk from a liberal surprised
anyone let's charge Obama for the deaths
occurring in his tenure like Zeca h1n1
Ebola and swine flu in which he did
nothing so that's Bryant Culpepper now
serious question why is it that lunatic
trumpets are disproportionately the ones
spreading these insane cure ideas is it
political like in other words they're so
desperate to defend from no matter what
that they'll tweet hey we've got a
simple cure for this this isn't this
isn't really as serious as some people
are telling you is it that if you're
gullible enough to vote for Trump you're
gullible enough to fall for some of
these sham cures like what is it that is
making this nonsense spread
disproportionately and overwhelmingly
from Trump supporters than from the left
I want to hear from you